[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up is Morgan uncensored Her
Majesty lies in state thousands line to
pay tributes to the late queen of an
emotional procession to Westminster Hall
for more accustomed to a very real
crisis should our politicians scrap
Party Conference season and get on with
fixing the country
and how much is too much food banks
funerals even Medical Treatments we're
all canceled for the funeral on Monday
is that right
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening and welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored another emotional day for the
country another day of Britain doing
what it does best pump pageantry class
and Remembrance for the greatest of all
monarchs I don't know about you but I
watched that procession of the coffin
today with a lump in my throat it was
incredibly moving and it really did show
us at our best while celebrating one of
the worst moments that we've had to deal
with as a nation
it felt like the world's been on pause
hasn't it since the late queen died and
quite rightly the death of any Head of
the State never mind one is beloved and
enduring as she was is a moment of
History we've all been living that
history in real time with the respect
and affection that this moment commands
but it was only eight days ago that the
new prime minister shook hands with her
majesty and took charge of a country
that frankly has been falling apart at
the scenes and as much as we've stitched
ourselves together to get through this
latest blow there's none holy mess
waiting on the other side after Monday's
funeral I've got no issue with
Parliament being suspended for these
days of national formal mourning it's
unfortunate they've just spent seven
weeks on summer holiday in the worst
cost living crisis in memory and frankly
it's utterly ridiculous that they're
about to pack up for another 26 days so
they can have their Party Conference
season for the uninitiated party
conferences are like music festivals for
political swats they all crammed
together in big sweaty Halls listening
to pointless self-again standardizing
outpourings about why they're better
than the other side and then they're all
going to get blind drunk night after
night after night is that what this
country needs right now the
conservatives literally just spent six
weeks in a rolling Party Conference to
let their new leader enough of the chat
our country is in crisis after the
funeral they should get back to work
well joining me now are some columnist
Tony Parsons talk to me contributor
Esther cracker and socialists also in
commentator Grace Blakely well okay
let's start with this Grace Blakely I
would imagine you're a regular attendee
to the labor party conversation
unfortunately yes so you know that when
I say it's just a great big Jolly I bet
it is why why would we want to be seeing
these scenes not quite of our members of
parliament on the last night after
another parties when they should be
dealing with this crisis I don't quite
agree with you on that peers because
whilst is true that conference is often
relatively fun it is also part of the
democratic process of the labor party
and that is part of the democratic
process and this country I agree with
you that it is reprehensible that
basically politics has been put on pause
um and I don't actually think that's
right I think that these politicians
should be getting back to dealing with
the cost of living crisis the massive
recession what can't they do here what
can't they do in Poland that they're
going to be doing at their conference
season particularly the labor party
conference right because the labor party
is supposed to be a democratic
organization where members can get
involved where unions can get involved
and say these are the issues that we're
facing put these policies into your
Manifesto that needs to happen because
quite frankly the people at the top of
all of these political parties aren't
listening to anyone at the moment all
right Esther I I just don't think they
should be doing this I've been to these
party conferences many times they are
just an excuse for a good old Jolly up
but I don't think they should have even
had the summer recess
and I think that reflected very badly on
the conservative party but I also think
it reflected badly on the other parties
in in Parliament because they didn't say
actually we need to get back to work
because this country's on its knees I
completely respect sort of the formal
morning period but again these companies
can can wait they can wait till next
summer or whenever but now is not the
time we keep talking about you know
we're going through this winter of this
content where people are going to have
to choose between eating and heating and
you literally have these these parties
that are not going to be working for the
next how many weeks what do you think of
this
um I don't I can't object to the party
conferences going ahead because I'm not
sure who they are I don't know I don't
know if kirst armor supports the strikes
or he doesn't support the strikes I
don't know if it's
um a new labor party or if it's um just
a Jeremy corbyn tribute band I don't
really know if the Tories have recovered
from Boris Johnson's Greta thundberg
tribute act you know I mean I really
think it's um important that the
identities of these political pies are
defined before the next general
elections they might argue well that's
why we have the Party Conference season
to actually you know work out what it is
I don't think they've got time to be in
this vanity project most of these party
conferences I would say 90 of the
speeches are completely irrelevant to
the National interest a lot of it is
Young politicians one of the bigger
names for themselves the speaker the
leader make their big speeches so what I
want to see them in Parliament thrashing
out the way to save this country from
what could be very very quickly yeah the
most serious financial crisis I think
the idea that people are going to be
choosing between Heating and eating is
is kind of behind behind the curve
really I think that there are going to
be plenty of people that can't afford
either and um
you know so it's um I think do you think
Liz truss is
policy on energy for example it's a
gigantic sum of money she's committed to
bailing people out with this cap on
energy will it be enough is it the right
thing to do well they should rating a
massive rod for our back they should
have they should have kept the brexit
promise which the the great Gove and
Bojo brexit promise was to scrap all the
EU green green
um tariffs scrap the bat on energy
and this is why Parliament needs to be
in session to scrutinize this plan to
scrutinize this legislation because list
trust is effectively just said let's
give 150 billion pounds to the energy
companies right particularly to the big
energy companies the fossil fuel
producers and cap People's Energy bills
are 2 500 pounds a year fine with the
cap but it's not actually a cap it's a
massive subsidy to some of the biggest
and most profitable corporations that we
have I don't understand I do not
understand why she didn't do a windfall
tax on the Energy company because they
shouldn't be making any profits even the
windfall because the thing is unless
you're willing to tax these companies at
100 which they won't do it's completely
unrealistic the winfall taxes actually
make up a very small
but the the point is
when the state gives money what we're
really doing is we are going to have to
pay this back we're giving money to BP
well the thing is this is actually the
most fiscally
um responsible thing to do this critical
moment and the reason the reason the
reason for that is if you cap it that's
right if if gas price is full the
difference that the taxpayer actually
has to pay is less if you just say we're
going to give you know families a
thousand pounds a month you have to
stick to that commitment for however
long regardless of what the market
prices for gas are so actually
we pay less as a brexit supporter
it seems to me I took a position I've
only remained I wasn't completely sure I
found it at a very complex argument my
gut feeling was I'd rather stay in
Europe and my issue is that we've had
the pandemic we skewed every way of
analyzing it really but as we've come
out of that as we get back into real
life the number of people who say to me
brexit is calling causing me problems
massively outweighs the number of people
saying thank God for brexit it's really
helped me in this way yeah at some point
brexit has to work doesn't it well I
think this is I think it's in the Last
Chance Saloon with this remain a prime
minister because for me it's a massive
disappointment for me like I feel the
promise has been completely betrayed who
do you blame for that I blame
um the the politicians that sold us
brexia and didn't keep their promises
yeah and Gove and um that for me the
benefits have not been worth the pain
that it's caused you know we're terrible
relations with um you know as a ground
war in Europe and we have terrible
relations with France yeah it's insane
it's absolutely I thought what she said
about friends
let me ask you I mean on brexit Labor's
position on the Kirsten has been we
won't try and reverse it but is there
going to be a moment not necessarily
right now but when we have a clearer run
at analyzing whether brexit is working
if you if it monsterably is against the
national interest and we can't seem to
make it work is there an argument for
labor to be a little bit more aggressive
and say what I suspect a lot of polls
are moving to which is actually maybe we
should have another referendum on this I
mean look brexit tore the labor party
apart
um and it's all the conservative party
apart in many ways it tore the country
apart and I think going back over it and
trying to rehash
actively damaging because the thing
about brexit was that the actual vote
said one thing and after that there was
a process the brexit was always a
process it was never a fixed thing that
was in the hands of politicians and it
was up to them to try and manage that
process in the National interest they
resolutely failed to do that at least in
part because of the massive divisions
that there were within major political
parties and obviously you know the
remainers within the labor party
basically brought down
um corbyn's government Corbin's Corbin's
government Corbin's leadership of the
labor party this trust is hard is not in
brexit she voted Romaine yeah so I just
don't think she's doing it I think I
think she's an African I think she's
made that she's she's got the Zeal of a
convert I disagree I think I think I
think she I think she is diplomatically
sound how can you possibly say that it's
inside
I want to move on to the national anthem
I had a big problem with all the
football being canceled last weekend I
thought that was the right I should have
canceled it this weekend well if you're
going to do it okay after this weekend
but they didn't and so now you've got a
few games back on a few goes back on
interestingly they've announced now that
at every Premier League game and League
game as you hear there's going to be
when they're played over the next few
days there will be a minute of Silence
they'll then play the national anthem
and then on the 70th minute there will
be Applause which I think is a great a
great thing for football to have their
their chance to pay tribute but
instantly UEFA who run of course the
champions league and the UEFA League
they have said you cannot play the
national anthem and what's been quite
interesting is people have decided to
take on us so tonight Rangers were
playing Napoli and this happened
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
s will look back at this week and see it
as the week that um Queen Elizabeth II
secured the union I think I think
increasingly I think that she
knew what she was doing when she went up
to Balmoral and she stayed at Balmoral
and she and you know the the in the
first few days were completely Scottish
surgeon you would have been watching the
last week yeah not publicly saying this
but thinking to yourself This is put
back I think the cause of Scottish
independence I don't think the
historians will look back as this on the
week that the union was saved I think
historians will look back on this week
as the week that Free Speech started to
die in this country because you know
we're on your show Pez this is Piers
Morgan uncensored and at the moment
there is massive censorship happening in
this country with people being arrested
nobody's having their doors kicked down
at three o'clock in the morning you know
a few you know spotty yobs get colored
because
I interviewed a guy uh I think it was on
Monday night and he had been arrested
right because he passed one of the
scenes of what they do with the new king
the proclamation he'd passed it and he
shouted out who elected him and for that
he got arrested well I tell you I I was
a punk during the Silver Jubilee and you
risk getting a kick in every time you
stepped out of the house now so you know
I mean things anyway
that gives a much more civilized I think
you know if you you know if you share
someone
um when they're
um walking behind their my mother's
coffin you know we're part of the world
I come from you know you're lucky to
keep your front teeth it's an
interesting point even if that person
is marching in a public display of the
royal family who has just paid a woman
who he claims he never met 10 million
dollars to make a court case go away
imagine if he had now it'd be really
really expensive but my point being this
is probably the most serious allegation
against the senior Royal in my lifetime
yeah he paid all these millions to a
woman he claims he didn't meet who made
serious allegations of sexual assault
against him and there he is marching in
a very public way is it is it actually
that outrageous that some members of the
public were really offended by Andrew's
presence there I I think that I thought
that I saw the footage I saw the footage
of the guy and I just think that there's
you know keep it in proportion the guy
wouldn't stop he kept on you know it's
Scotland he's a is around working-class
Scots I'm afraid if he just didn't he
didn't know how to make his protest make
it an appropriate manner he just thought
that the world should hear his opinion
you know it's a challenge I totally
agree with Grace here oh my God
stand upside down Everything's changed
this week right the reason I say that is
I do think that if you actually start to
suppress people's opposition to the idea
of a monarchy in any form they want to
express their protest if you do that I
think you actually you hasten the
beginning you can't just let when that
coffin is is walking down the mountain
you can't just let some but these people
want well
unfortunately actually I think you can I
think the thing about free speech I
think it was Churchill he said you know
some people think it free speech is
whatever they think and if you disagree
with them it's an outrage yeah the point
about free speech is actually that you
tolerate people being very distasteful
if not offensive yeah but at the moments
I get all that but it's just a really
naive middle class
supposition to think that you can just
stand in a crowd you can offend all the
people around you and there'll be no
reaction you have to there'll be no
reason
State response to you but yeah
who literally said I have a blank piece
of paper here to a policeman if I was to
write you know F the monarchy on this
would you arrest me and he said yes
I want to move on to a moment today with
Sharon Osborne was out meeting people
who were queuing to come and pay their
respects to the queen and Sharon I think
you took a bit of a turn the interview
she had with the with the members of the
British public take a look
I love you I love everything you stand
for you should be prime minister
I love you oh my God we can't let these
crazy people these crazy [ __ ]
screaming so what I've always said the
British public have sound judgment about
these things
Mr Grace
um I unfortunately peers uh I don't
think that that would be my ideal uh
we can't actually agree with more things
than you realize I want to play a clip
that went virally it's actually it turns
out it's quite an old clip but it just
made me laugh this is a bunch of vegans
marching into a supermarket to throw
roses on meat
thank you
roses real roses on to slanted me
apparently in honor as an honor for the
fact that the animals involved had lost
their lives here's my question
which is they are murdering roses to do
that they are ripping roses out of the
ground ending their lives they are
murdering living
roses oh to go and do that
outrageous two things of the Roses in
this do you I mean for God's sakes I'm
not even a vegan and that's a silly
argument
um quick question before I let you go
because
um we're going to throw you out a bit of
someone who likes the royal family
um
again
I haven't mentioned that yet Republican
the issue of migrants is not going to go
away we've had record numbers coming
over the channel everyone agrees this
can't go on like this you can't have the
numbers just exponentially Rising
everyone thinks it's horrifying and
dangerous especially for the young
people that are coming over as well
what do we do about this the Rwanda plan
seems to me completely one of the better
prices
it's the dumbest idea of all time right
it's never going to work it's wrong on
every level it's never going to work
legally morally
people number people are coming up
coming from France and the I you know
one of the one of the uh things I regret
about um brexit is that there's there's
a ground war in Europe and we're
actually inside the French area are our
enemies it's absolutely insane one of
the best speeches about uh the death of
the queen was made by macron
um and I share the standards the stand
the standard view of macron as someone
who smeared the Oxford AstraZeneca
vaccine totally Unforgiven yeah we gave
a beautiful tribute yeah got rid of
their monarchy several hundred okay so
what do we have what do we do about the
sheer volume of people trying to get
into the country you know it's illegal
but I believe in Asylum I believe in the
refugee system but clearly our system is
not working you can't just have an
opening the only
moral solution is that you smash the
gangs you smash the game
this is always brought out as a solution
it's impossible because you'd basically
you're arguing to
in terms of the energy crisis at the
food crisis this is just the beginning
of a global crisis associated with
climate breakdown that is going to see
millions of people forced to move away
from their homes we need to come up with
a solution that allows people what is
the move when they need to move
basically we need to work together as
countries that are on the receiving end
of migrants by the way the vast majority
of migrants are in countries in the
global South none of the countries
what is this solution you know we need
to basically come up with a way of
sharing out what is the burden of
hosting and actually it's not even often
a burden because let's be real we are
running out of workers
immigration then there is
would social cohesion would look like if
you have all these people from different
parts of the world just get crashed we
are all ready
having a stable process of managed
migration that allows people to come
over here
if the queen was you know an older a
mother of someone just a normal person
who would be looking after her it would
be a Filipino nurse you would be a nurse
come here perfectly legally exactly and
that's why we need to have a management
system I'm not talking about we're not
talking about the legal process of
immigration
we're talking about people who don't
come here through the legal process well
exactly we're talking about what we're
talking about the whole thing together
are you under the impression that these
people coming in dinghies are doctors
engineers and people who can to be
honest with the NHS some of them
actually are when you come out while
they're coming illegally because they've
often been you know booted out of their
country they've
we should always leave Grace Blakely
with someone calling her ridiculous so
I'm glad it was you Esther Grace we're
going to lose you because you don't want
to talk about into the rules you don't
care I don't mind talking about it yeah
I I don't care and also I'm a republican
I think that this should be the point at
which one again all right well I think
exactly we've called you ridiculous
I'm quite happy to be Buddha thank you
very much as always a joy to see you
well something next a YouTube can stay
uh already criticized this frustration
with various types of 10 from King
Charles be held to the exact same
standards as his late mother will debate
that
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it was the longest apprenticeship
in history but King Charles III is here
as our Monarch he's going to take some
getting used to for everybody including
himself the new sovereigns already faced
criticism face past record of asserting
political opinions as well as negative
press this week about redundancies at
Clarence House he's also been lambasted
by the traditionally sensitive corners
of the internet for his frustration with
a leaking pen the late Queen reacted in
the same way asked the trolls well
probably not but should King Charles
face constant comparisons with his
mother is it time to embrace King
Charles for the many years rather than
the woman that his mother was so joining
me now is King Charles is goddaughter
India Hicks plus Tony Esther is still
here India thank you so much uh for
joining me you are going to be at the
funeral you're also going to be at the
middle of the Queen's body at the very
end of this extraordinary period of
mourning what are your feelings about
all this as someone who's obviously so
close to the family
I think that we're seeing
um in general an overwhelming uh
unification of people wanting to pay
their respects I think you've been
highlighting a few incidences here and
there I think we can all agree that our
kingdom our Commonwealth and the world
have come together to really thank an
extraordinary woman for the job she did
we now have to rely on an extraordinary
man which I think King Charles is to be
anything like as good harmonic as his
mother which will be an incredibly tough
challenge for anybody it doesn't matter
in my view she was the greatest moment
we've ever had
knowing him as you do is The Optimist
job Princess Diana famously said in the
panoramans I think the top job will be
Beyond him but it looks to me from the
first few days it's not Beyond him at
all and he's rising to his challenge I
think what's interesting is he's so
completely different to his mother so
that it'll be a very a blank canvas on
which to paint his own picture which is
important he will have a very strong
Queen beside him we know that Camilla is
a very strong woman look what she
survived already
um and I think together they have a very
good chance at doing an awful lot of
good and I think Charles has been vocal
in the past about what he uh feels uh
his passions
um he was prescient in his view on uh
ecology and the environment he did
things that none of us even began to
think about the word green
sustainability all of that didn't exist
but he can't do that now he can't but
why didn't you think he can keep to that
pledge I think that I'm an ambassador
for the princess trust I've been there
for two years I've seen up close and
personal the change that that trust has
done it's been in place since 1976 who
imagined that he would be able to do
that that is now a global Foundation the
astonishing amount of good it does is is
incredible and I think that he can step
away from that that will continue to be
its own motor its own course and he will
be able to now step into the shoes that
he has to have has he got to keep his
temper when his Pen's leaking
I think he is someone who is grieving he
is exhausted he has had to be on show
publicly every minute of the day for the
past five days it's an enormous thing to
undertake I think you're allowed to have
a bit of a temper tantrum on your pen
leaks I actually thought it was quite
endearing I've blown my stack over pens
before especially when they're legal
over your hands Tony what do you think I
mean you wrote a great piece today in
the sun and it was about why the queen
was the biggest star of them all big of
The Beatles I've always felt that and he
can judge it by the sort of overall way
that even American Presidents behave
when they were around her but Charles
has got to start all over again now you
know he's been this Apprentice but now
he is King I think the reason uh
hereditary monarchy Works in this
country is that every Monarch earns the
love of um of our people and I think
that the Queen to me what's incredible
is that she became more important in her
extreme old age you know she was
absolutely I can't remember
um one word that a politician or
celebrity said during uh the covered
pandemic but I can remember we're told
Clarity those two four minute speeches
in the spring of 2020 yeah two four
minutes away unless you know they're so
brief so brief so devastating you know
just those those words you know our
Street's not empty they're full of love
uh seared into the national
Consciousness
um now my parents were not monarchists
my parents were not royalists um but the
the photograph where they look happiest
is when they were 20 years old going to
Buckingham Palace to meet King George VI
to collect my dad's distinguished
service medal no they loved that King
they loved that shy kind Brave right and
you were saying about your mother that
she's on the verge of aquatic story
possibly unprecedented triple coronation
well and I love what you've just said
now you don't have to be a monarchist to
find pride in those moments their
leaders these are leaders of our
countries umly is the faith and leaders
and and so many ways yes my mum uh went
to King George VI coronation in a little
green cape
um and then she went to the queens and
if she has the stamina and the strength
to survive another year she could well
be into her third coronation I think
that's Guinness because everybody's ever
done that that's quite a me it's an
amazing she's an amazing person she's
the same she's the same breed as the
queen they are extraordinary women women
who have survived in a tough old man's
world think when the queen took that
Throne what she had to do who she had
put up you were a bridesmaid one year
Charles and Donna's I was what was it
like you remember it or not I remember
it very well
um it was it was amazing I tell you what
was amazing looking back now at this
grand old age 55
um was the crowds and it's very rare
that you see crowds who aren't grieving
or aren't angry or aren't demonstrated
these were crowds who were Jubilee they
were Jubilee they were in Jubilation of
the whole thing and and they were
excited and at that stage it was a fairy
tale wedding we all believed the fairy
tale was going to end in the most
wonderful way and and that was really
remarkable a lot of people came out a
lot of people came out yeah amazing
one of the poll came out this week very
supportive of Charles his his popularity
surging as people think he'll be a good
King from 30 odd percent to 60 odd
percent in the space of three months so
immediate reaction for the public very
very positive 94 loved his first TV
address the only issue he has is age
profile of of support younger people
under 50 are supportive of of him
whereas older people are much more
supportive what does he do about the
youngin 73 you know my 10 year old
daughter looked at the TV and went he's
very old
she thinks I'm very old um what does he
do about the youth how does he connect
with them I think it just it's kind of
he just he just settled into his role I
think I think people
love for the royal family when they
actually connect with them on a personal
level you can't keep comparing him to
the queen because you know he's not 26
Just Married with with kids right he's
he's a lot older um so he just needs to
settle into his role and the love will
come it just he has to curate his own
image and keep doing what he's been
doing so well that's why I also think if
you look at sort of um stratification as
well so it depends on sort of your
community background whether you come
from a family that already loves the
royal family sort of what your
Allegiance is to I suppose the
Commonwealth and to the United Kingdom
that all plays a role in who warms to
him final words well I was gonna have a
thought there which is I think that
actually Charles and Camilla it's a sort
of Fantastic Four they've got William
and Kate yeah very powerful yeah William
and Kate do have the attention
I think we're in good hands I think the
the bloodstock is good yes uh good to
see you the pens are a little faulty
yeah it depends on he's a new pet uh
Tony stay with me because we're in a
debate after the break whether the real
spanner in the works of all this could
be Prince Harry's tell-all book about
the royal family including his father
should he Pulpit as I think he should or
is he allowed to have his say we'll talk
about that after the break I think very
much
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well Harry Megan joined the rest of the
royal family today presenting a united
front for the procession of the lake
Queens coffin princess William and Harry
walks side by side behind the coffin is
at left Bucky in Palace the family
entered Westminster Hall together Oprah
Winfrey has suggested that the late
Queen's death provides an opportunity
for peacemaking
is she right or is this just a temporary
truce to get through a week that should
all be about of course Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II well of course the big
spanner in the works was looming for the
royal family something I know personally
they're very very concerned about is
Harry is apparently explosive tell-all
Memoir which has been written and is
ready to roll off the presses joining me
now to discussed his son columnist Tony
Parsons talks if you contributor Esther
crack Laura Megan to Porter Paula Roan
Adrian and best-selling author Douglas
Murray is in New York let me start with
you Douglas welcome to the show
um I wrote a column for New York Post
that really hit a nerve this week about
Harry should pulp this book but now
we've had this dramatic event we've lost
the queen his father is now King and he
made a statement saying it's time to
honor my father King Charles III how is
that compatible with a tell-all book
which will be presumably as most of his
art prongs have been about his father
very critical of the king
uh yes I I think they're not at all
compatible and I think this must in some
ways be a very lonely time for sorry uh
by all accounts on the day of uh the
lake Queen's death he was having to
arrange his own travel arrangements and
was being reminded back that had he been
part of the family still he'd have been
uh you know looked after by them but he
had to sort of go his own way because he
said go his own way uh now he's seeing
some of the costs of that one of the
costs of it I'm sure is a certain
coldness of the family uh how could you
not
um God what you say uh when a family
member has said so many things about a
family ending to say more
um how could he expect he ought what
expect to be treated entirely warmly and
they've already said so many untrue
things throughout the royal family so
many hurtful things and a promising more
to come of course he should pull the
Memoir it's the decent thing to do made
plenty of money from other deals from
Netflix from Spotify and others doesn't
to release the Memoir now I I completely
concur with that but Paula you think he
should be in a pub publish the book of
course he should of course why he should
have the opportunity to have his set he
hasn't stopped yapping for two years
literally he and his wife barely a week
goes by without them sticking my knife
into the royal family in the monarchy so
what do you mean he's got to have his
say he doesn't stop having his say we
could say that about the Press too
couldn't we we could say that about the
millions of stories that have been
um reported in the Press about Twitter
going wild we know that reports have
been done haven't it two members of the
royal family constantly publicly
attacking the royal family and the
monarchy of course the media are going
to respond people said to me when are
you going to stop criticizing Meghan
Markle and Prince Harry when they stop
attacking the royal families even in the
tone it's very aggressive they're
attacking the royal family they are is
that the case is it the case that they
are telling their truth that they are
finally
they're finally getting an opportunity
there is no such thing as someone's
individual truth when Meghan Markle
talks about my truth it doesn't exist
there is the truth which are facts and
there's everything else and the problem
is you don't have your own version the
problem with with problem with that
argument is is that is exactly why they
needed to have this book because you
will deny you will deny their truth and
you can't continue to do that why don't
they be allowed to tell blatant lies
about the royal family well because they
don't believe they are telling let me
give you an example
Meghan Markle told Oprah Winfrey that
their son Archie was not going to be a
prince because of his skin color that's
what she inferred in the answer right so
you're very careful there people as you
may know you're very excited because
that is what she inferred what she said
which is how you started this
conversation and this is why we need to
be careful because this is such an
emotive topic during this of course
exceptionally sad period of time where
we know that they are a grieving family
and we know that they have done their
absence
I'm not talking about now I'm talking
about when this book lands Tony I think
it's it's going to be like an unexploded
bomb when this thing goes off it's going
to be something which has been ticking
away ticking away I know the palace are
incredibly concerned much more so now
Charles is king because they also fear
Harry might have a go at Camilla who's
known the queen consort of this country
yeah try and settle scores going back to
his parents marriage uh breaking up I do
think there's the law of diminishing
returns I don't think anything will ever
have the impact of that Oprah in
interview I don't think anything
because you know it was so unchallenged
you know she let Oprah looked like the
worst journalist in the world everything
that was put out there that was put out
there was uncompletely unchallenged and
um and and I think people were shocked
and hurt in this country because I I
went I was among the crowds at Windsor
the day they got married and there was a
genuine real love and there was no
racism and whatsoever towards Meghan
Markle you know and the idea that from
the press in this country
I know what I wrote for example you
don't know what this country is embraced
the whole thing you don't know what
existed for her and what she didn't know
that
because I noticed that we're focusing on
Megan
as well you are concerned about with
this book is the truth
about the truth which is often
completely untrue here's my problem with
it if all they did was tell the truth
that's one thing but 17 different
statements for me open interview alone
were proven to be untrue we still don't
know who this supposed Royal was who
raised concerned about their child's
skin colors I do wish that they actually
said who it was because I thought that
was very mature for them I don't have a
problem with Harry coming up with the
book actually he's not quite an extreme
life no 10 years in the Army you know I
don't have a problem with that but I
think I like I suspect with with good
reason that it's not going to be
tasteful that it could be it's an attack
it surely he understands now the
fictional truth behind Megan's screen
just Murray um Douglas there's a kind of
perception here that they're doing all
this because it plays really well for
them in America but the New York Post
cleared its front page for a very
mocking image of of Meghan Markle
recently looking like a a toddler and a
tiara throwing tantrum after tantrum
what is the mood you think amongst the
majority of Americans about what they've
been doing
well there's a deep skepticism about it
um some support uh but also I think just
a lot of embarrassmented a sort of
embarrassment about the fact that Mark
will joined the royal family there was
as as several people who said incredible
Goodwill towards her and towards EU I
never saw anything in the British press
that was even remotable of Megan herself
on the day itself of the wedding to been
a happier day the sight of Prince
Charles walk is his new daughter-in-law
up the aisle
um escorting her mother in Saint
George's Chapel it was such a sign as it
was the the photographs of the queen
king her first great grandchild of of
Megan and Harry this was healing things
and there was so much good will around
the world and I'm afraid that Megan and
Harry have through their own shins just
thrown that good will away on both sides
of the event and the trouble started
actually the trouble started when the
whole Fury over her father blew up uh
and her decision to then completely
disown him and from that moment on you
can see the trajectory of the criticism
in the media building and building
because they then embarked on this huge
victimhood tour where they kept being
frankly hypocritical about things like
you know preaching about carbon
footprinting catching private jets all
the time and so on but also constantly
whining playing the victim the complete
antithesis of what the queen for example
uh stood for Douglas thank you for
joining me as always spot on thank you
to my panel there is one bit of good
news this week Greg's have just
announced that they are closing their
shops on Monday which means no vegan
sausage rolls for the British public so
there's always a silver lining in every
cloud we're going to talk after the
break actually uh about this closure of
the country is it right so many things
have been shut down is it right that on
Monday pretty much everything foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Queen's funeral is of course a national
holiday the idea is that everyone gets
to watch it and to say goodbye to our
greatest Monarch it's a state occasion
in practice it means school closures
shop closures Medical Treatments
postponed a struggling economy on
standby even people having to postpone
their own funerals because of the
funeral rule on Monday even the golden
arches will go dark at least until five
o'clock McDonald's converted it will
shut all 1300 of his UK stores allow
staff to pay their respects so is this
right is really the question or is it
over the top I've got two experts with
me Jenny Cleveland the broadcaster and
Yvonne Richmond Tully who's the CEO of
atal loss so let's talk about this
because when I just heard that Greg's
closing down on Monday I mean I did have
a ride chuckle because it means no
vegans sausage rolls other people I
think have been ridiculous in The Virtue
signaling the Met Office saying they
weren't going to do weather updates
because it might be disrespectful it's
absurd however I do think that Monday is
a unique occasion what do you think it
absolutely is of course you know we've
seen it on the media haven't we all
through these last few days Our Queen is
so special to so many people and she's
part of our heritage as a nation here
but she's valued by people all over the
world so there is an important moment
here in in marking her death and having
these 10 days how far do you take your
like Center pass got themselves into a
hell of a mess because they said they
were going to basically kick everybody
out at their Parks because of the
funeral then on the mounting media
pressure they said all right you can
stay in but you have to stay inside now
they've even you turn that I think and
so on it's it's difficult if you're if
you're like a company like Center parks
and you've got thousands of people
staying there what do you do if your own
staff want to go and pay their respects
yes I mean that is difficult isn't it
we're very used to bank holidays and uh
and in bank holidays our hospitality
industry doesn't close down and so on so
I think we have to acknowledge that we
you know this is a bank holiday but it's
also different because we didn't know it
was coming and so lots of people have
had things cancel and okay I mean Jenny
I just feels quite strongly this woman
was a unique woman 70 years on the on
the throne we can at least surely give
her one day where the country does
actually shut down and pays respects to
one person my can concern with all of
this is that so it's been left up to
businesses to decide whether or not to
to shut and I feel that a lot of
businesses are doing this out of fear of
being castigated for doing the wrong
thing or being seen to be or because
their own staff want to pay there are
ways that you can let you you can say
okay if you want to if you want to go
and and be in the street go and be in
the street if you want to watch the
ceremony you can watch it we'll allow it
to happen but I feel like for example
particularly with schools I think school
shutting is a mistake I think there's a
real opportunity for kids to learn you
see I couldn't disagree more I really
think that I think every child of the
country should actually be able to be at
home with their family how many families
they appears how many families do you
think given this bank holiday are going
to take their kids and educate them
about constitutional monarchy a lot are
going to watch the funeral together a
lot I mean I would say I would say I
would say the vast majority of the
country well actually what I think that
if schools had a special day where
everybody was watching it together and
you could learn about the monarchy my
brother-in-law took assistance
playing on computer games because
there's nowhere to go because there's
there's no Virginia
surely we can give the queen 24 hours I
think that uh I know I really want my
kids to see it I will be my kids will be
will be watching uh the funeral but the
funeral ends at a certain point in the
afternoon and then I'm not be going to
be able to give them the education that
they would have at school where they
would learn about it
a history teacher and I don't know about
you know constitutional monarchy
explaining around to my house and I'll
give them a little oh thanks but I think
most people when faced with a bank
holiday won't be using it as a learning
moment and I think that this is not a
this is a this is a short I don't think
it's a learning moment it's a moment of
paying tribute and respect I think to
Queen Elizabeth II this is our last
chance Monday proper chance as a nation
yes to come completely together and say
for today it's all about this woman and
our gratitude yes absolutely but I I I
take your point completely because
they're they're really wrong
there are really mixed views aren't
there about about our monarchy and
um actually it's a very small one
there's a small number the thing about
our monarchy is it it works because we
consent to it we the majority of us want
it and once it becomes something where
you you must have this attitude I agree
with us feel this way it all crumbles
apart no Republican thinking person has
to watch the funeral no one's being
forced to watch it but everyone's been
given the chance and I think I think
that is the right thing to do and that's
the importance I've got to leave it
there uh thank you both very much indeed
great to see you both I appreciate it
that's it from me uh whatever you're up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
I'm telling you've done and this is talk
TV the most memorable moment in my
career without sounding completely
conceited has to be interviewing
president Trump in the open Office in
the White House particularly little red
button he had on his desk I have no idea
what he did his interview went until I
wanted more rules is going to launch a
nuclear strike on North Korea or open up
a shark pit that I've been falling to
turn out he pressed it right at the end
of the interview and then walked to
Butler with a train that came back today
it was the diet Cooper
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Sarah Suleiman tens of
thousands of people are queuing through
London right now to witness Queen
Elizabeth lying in state the gates of
Westminster Hall opened at 5 PM for mems
the public to pay their respects there
are warnings the wait time could be up
to 35 hours earlier senior members of
the royal family followed the Queen's
procession to Westminster Hall King
Charles the Princess Royal and Princess
William and Harry were among those
walking behind Queen Elizabeth's coffin
as a mark of respect McDonald's say
they'll close their 1300 branches in the
UK on Monday the day of the funeral it
comes after a number of shops
supermarkets and gyms say they'll also
close
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]